[Music]
foreign
[Music]
might the children of barncroft primary
school be heading the musical stardom
kids on vocals parents handling video
and editing with this cover of an 80s
pop classic You're The Voice by John
Farnham they're shooting for that most
hallowed of British Traditions topping
the charts with a Christmas number one
single
foreign
not for fortune or fame though they're
much more modest aim is to keep their
school lights on and their teachers
employed
[Music]
I've been a teacher since the late 90s
this is the worst I've ever known it
Barn cross head says the school is in a
huge financial black hole and it's not
alone
it's absolutely Countrywide
um I think if you spoke to any head
teacher in the country they would say
that their school has been really badly
hit by this earlier in the year teachers
wages went up but the government did not
give schools the money to pay for this
leaving them with serious budgets
deficits barncroft hopes they can raise
enough money to buy solar panels for the
roof cutting soaring energy bills might
mean the school won't have to make staff
redundant in a year or two the teaching
assistants that vulnerable and special
needs children rely on for support
despite having fun with the video the
situation has left parents desponded I'm
really angry and you know our children
they they you know as we say like our
children are the future really we need
to invest in them it's a bigger problem
that's affecting all schools everywhere
um and it's it's very very worrying for
the future of Education in this whole
country you're the voice try and
understand it make a noise and make it
[Music]
just once yeah
and that was it and he knew it after one
practice yes the Christmas number one
would of course be a fantastic present
for the kids and the parents of this
school but a better one would be the
funding they need indeed the funding
that every cash Strat School across this
country needs and isn't receiving at the
moment Rory challenge Al Jazeera London